Kesha dismisses her sexual-assault
lawsuit against dr. Luke he can confirm
the 29 year old singer has dropped her
lawsuit in California against the music
producer after fighting a contentious
legal battle for nearly four years
a representative from Cash's legal team
tells us quote Kesha has dismissed her
California action without prejudice
while she pursues her appeal and other
legal claims in the New York courts the
New York courts are of course handling
Kesha's other lawsuit against dr. Luke
as it pertains to music the tic-tock
singer hasn't released new tunes in over
four years
her attorney explained quote Kesha is
focused on getting back to work and has
delivered 28 new songs to the record
label we have conveyed to Sony Music and
the label kesh a strong desire to
release her next album and single as
soon as possible in February a New York
judge denied Cash's request to be
released from her recording contract
after she initially argued she couldn't
make music with someone she claimed had
sexually assaulted her dr. Luke has
denied the allegations et has reached
out to the producers rep for comment